this microwave listens to popcorn
popping to perfectly cook popcorn every
time and the Iowa storm chasing Network
recently unveiled a 10,000 pound armored
van specifically designed to get closer
than ever to tornadoes Vsauce Kevin here
this is my flow
the Seulong cortex headset hopes to
merge the real world with virtual
reality the idea is to overlay a virtual
environment on your physical
surroundings it works using a head
position tracker and a game controller
tracker along with a sensor package that
Maps the world around you basically
turning the real world into a video game
developer kits are available for
pre-order right now neuro scape lab
created a real-time 3d visualisation of
the human brain the colors represent
source power and connectivity and the
estimated information transfer can be
seen as pulses of light moving along the
fiber tracks connecting the regions of
the brain and you can even fly through
the brain activity of someone wearing an
EEG cap using a gamepad space generator
is a room concept that allows you to
create any type of room you can imagine
winner of the 2013 red dot concept award
the pre-programmed module cells can be
raised or lowered to transform the once
flat platform into any number of 3d
arrangements creating the space for a
fashion show a theater of any kind or a
game installation like a maze
Facebook's facial recognition technology
is nearly as accurate at recognizing
faces as you are their research project
titled deep face can look at two photos
and regardless of the angle or lighting
tell with ninety seven point two five
percent accuracy whether they contain
the same face something humans can do at
an accuracy of ninety seven point five
three percent this new technology is not
currently used on the Facebook website
but ostensibly could eventually be used
to link every photo of you online to
your Facebook account
Howdy's traffic light recognition system
counts down the time remaining until a
red light turns green it works by
reading the automated signals from the
city's central traffic computer and
sending that data to the driver it will
also let you know if you can make it
through a green light or if you should
start braking but there's no current
date for when this will be available in
the US
yes a new study shows that forgetting is
actually an active process specifically
that a protein called Musashi is
necessary for memory loss and hopefully
this research can someday lead to
treatments for Alzheimer's disease this
360 degree Milky Way panorama from NASA
features two and a half million
snapshots taken over a decade and
finally stitched together for the first
time finally below to explore this
monumental space image ty ddong hopes to
train your dog to put away its toys it
uses sensors to detect the weight of a
toy when the dog puts it back in the bin
and then dispenses a treat rewarding
your pooch for cleaning up finally
firefight films created bigger than life
ice caves which is the first documented
drone flight through ice caves
I'm gonna leave you with a robot that
learns by imitating a human and that
performs that task better than the human
and as always thanks for watching